uh guys let's talk about this game
tonight because what we saw was not what
anybody really expected to see but
rodney we heard the guys talk about the
coaches you heard chris collinsworth
during the game say this titans team the
defense is playing with attitude that
starts with their head coach mike frable
he's a former teammate of yours what did
he bring tonight with his team i thought
mike brabel was fantastic i think he
should be in a coach of the year
conversation think about this he loses
his very best player they have to fly
out to the west coast and they come out
here and flat out kick the rams but i
look at mike frable this team takes on
the personality of rabel he's smart he's
focused and he was a guy that worked
extremely hard i thought they played
excellent catherine this building is
stunned right now stunned i don't think
they can believe it they have been
playing perfect football for so long but
for tennessee i just think it's about
disrespect i think this is one of the
more disrespected teams in all of
football i think rabel is disrespected i
think tannehill is disrespecting jeffrey
simmons based on what was happening in
miami jeffrey simmons is disrespected
and i think the tennessee titans are
disrespected just given this is some
team out there in tennessee and
everybody overlooks them they play hard
defensive physical football and they
look like a team is going to be around
for the long haul yeah now that the top
team in the afc going back home to
tennessee a nice little cushion to have
after this victory here in l.a but
rodney you look at the rams and what
sean mcvay was unable to do with his
team in particular in that first half we
saw some adjustments made in the second
but where could he have coached better
in this one well he got out coach and i
just thought that in the first half he
was very conservative everything was
drop back passes he came back in the
second half and started doing some hurry
up offense and some bootlegs but to me
he just didn't have his team prepared
when i saw him in warm-ups i said this
team does not it doesn't look like it's
fired up tennessee looked fired up and i
told you that
so i just i don't understand that you
have an opportunity you just signed bond
miller so you should be excited you
should be ready to run through a brick
wall and they don't do that they just
come out here flat layer egg and i was
just really disappointed with sean mcvay
they couldn't block him at all that was
that was the story the beginning of the
game jeffrey simmons was just blowing up
every play every passing play and you
made a good point right there i like
when they when they started going up
tempo started running this offense a
little bit more up tempo you started
seeing those guys tire out but this was
the beginning of the game simmons took
over absolutely and i told you i said
jeffrey simmons is a guy he's a very
good player but no one gives him enough
credit but also we talked about deniko
alltree yeah coming in you know making
it
kevin byer we talked about harold landry
the third with nine sacks just this is a
very tough disciplined team and it's
gonna be a hard out in the playoffs i'll
tell you that yeah they were able to
find a way to get to matthew stafford
they caused him havoc they he couldn't
really have any answers for this titans
defense in this one jack and that's a
problem when you've got your quarterback
with a 7-1 team coming into this game
and he's not able to find answers with
this titan's d i don't remember seeing
mcvay look this puzzle this confused
since maybe even the super bowl do you
remember the super bowl the belichick
super bowl game this week this felt
similar to that you see any similar
strategies that bravel brought out
absolutely he played a lot of zone early
on and when he pressured he pressured up
the middle and he played a lot of
man-to-man coverage on third down it was
basically very similar to what coach
belichick did in the super bowl similar
result too yeah absolutely you see the
five-game win streak for the titans now
and you look at this team and they're
rolling at the right time in the season
rodney how dangerous can this tennessee
team be as we approach you know the
second half of the season yeah yeah i
mean defensively we saw what happened
offensively i wasn't really impressed
they have to find a way to consistently
be able to run the ball and we don't
know what ryan tannehill is we know that
he's a good athlete but can he carry
this team on his back if he has to
that's what we're gonna find and it was
interesting to see without the king
everybody was going so now all this
weight goes on tannehill's shoulders but
really it was the defense that
shouldered all of that added
responsibility you know the pick six
went all the way back for a touchdown
then they had the other interception and
ended up at the one yard line so the
defense was creating the scoring
opportunities they were paying them off
yeah adrian peterson making his debut
here in this game did you notice
anything from him or yeah he looked like
he was 36 years old
think about it he's playing with some of
these 23 24 25 year old guys so he'll
get it going once he gets his shirt and
they're beating really talented teams
tap like i'm thinking about buffalo
handled them kansas city blew them out
6-0 they are against teams who were in
the playoffs last year so tells you what
this team is that's a good point
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports